[Music]
ariana grande's new album is out and
there is a lot to talk about we're not
even gonna waste any time let's jump
right in we've decoded the seven biggest
revelations starting with a music video
for a break up with your girlfriend I'm
bored we gotta just jump to the very end
because plot twist done re ends up with
a girlfriend who looks a lot like Ari
[Music]
okay so this kind of sets up the whole
album in a way because thank you next is
really all about well self love feeling
empowered and in my opinion it's her
most honest work to date totally agree
and now of course fans were wondering if
she was gonna talk about her ex the late
Mac Miller and it looks like she does
while also seemingly explaining how hard
it was on her relationship with
ex-fiance Pete Davidson
take a listen
[Music]
it breaks you
[Music]
they love that song me too that one
really oh that one heartstrings
so speaking of peed a lot of fans
thought NASA was gonna also be about the
SNL star because of this photo he's
rocking a NASA logo on his shirt not
only did our EES friend Victoria Monet
and debunk that but the song is actually
about wanting space get it
NASA space yeah and she eventually
alludes to outgrow in a relationship and
wanting to have well self discover keep
me in your bed and me under
[Music]
but the song that's generating a whole
lot of buzz is bloodline it's actually
fun it's pretty catchy and Katie's
dancing and it really falls in line with
the theme of this album not settling for
less than she deserves
a she shouldn't know don't you dare but
in January she actually tweeted it's
about wanting somebody but not enough
for them to be in your bloodline kind of
savage just speculating maybe this is
about Pete which would kind of explain
that quick engagement just a thought
[Music]
and don't blink because these next three
are all about the famous shout out she
gives starting with NSYNC which we're
dying dead and break up with your
girlfriend I'm bored
she totally samples the band's song it
makes me ill tears in syncs version and
here's her version ex tup Rihanna she
totally references the singers famous
beauty line venti beauty and how
appropriate is this the song is called
make up
[Music]
like the Fanta Beauty kid I need a
Rihanna re oh girl moment something
please take us on that journey and last
but not least Troye Sivan makes a little
cameo on the album at the beginning of
in my head take a listen
lover this version of a pattern that
you've created in your head that you are
trying to but cannot make you can't love
you way too long enough didn't happen
coming up his life advice is just spot
on
yes.can lovely my friend - I want a
voicemail but we want to know what song
was your favorite on the album let us
know and of course be sure to subscribe
to all things et until next time I'm at
Halle underscore Stephens and I'm Katie
underscore Krause bye for now
toodles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]